T
NOW.
DUNKING, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
WHEN YOU HEAR THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENT THAT MORNING AND
SUPPORTED?
>> IT IS FASCINATING HERE, SO
WE WILL LEVERAGE.
HAVE NOMINATED FOR 2001, THEY
HAVE AN APPLE SNOWMAN.
FOR THEM TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
MONTHS OVER THE WHOLE ELECTION
HERE.
AND WE, RAN WHAT HAPPENED?
BUT OUT OF THAT.
THEY HAVE BEEN AFTER FOR THREE
DAYS.
SO, THE NEVER KEVIN OR AS I
HAVE ANAHOLA COLIN PFA, TO
PREVENT THE CANOPY PASSING FOR
MORE.
EVERY TIME THAT THEY GET, THEY
ASKED FOR MORE.
IF YOU LOOK AT ABOUT WHAT THEY
HAD A LEVELLER THAN A MINORITY.
ANOTHER QUICK POINT, IF YOU
DON'T LIKE HIM BUT THERE IT IS
ONE VOTE.
BUT LUMBERTON AT A.
THAT IS, HE WOULD NOMINATE
DONALD TRUMP THINK ABOUT IN
JANUARY SAID.
EIGHT HOURS AWAY FROM THE
SECOND EVER THIRD GENERATION.
IT IS TELL YOU HOW THIS IS NOT
A SERIOUS AND A FIVE.
THE HOLD OF IT IS NOT CLEAR IF
PEOPLE.
HAD TO OVERTURN AN ELECTION, HE
PIVOTED MOTHER THE MARKER THAT
IS IN THAT HOLDING.
BUT IT SHOWS YOU THAT THEM,
IT'S A FIVE-YEAR ENTERPRISE.
THE PROTESTERS,.
OR CALL IF YOU, WELL NOT BE
CUTER ONWARD.
IT'S NOT SERIOUS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT GOVERNING.
>> FIGURE THAT OUT ENOUGH.
I WONDER IF THAT, OR AS
REPUGNANT.
I MEAN, THE IDEA THAT YOU HAVE
A SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS
STANDING IN A PLACE WHERE, AT
THE TIME, WITH NICHOLAS
HUNDRED.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT YOU
THUNDER.
>> BUT PEOPLE THIRD OUT BY THE
PRESIDENT.
AND NOW HE IS OFFICIALLY,
FORMALLY NOMINATED BY ONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HELPED TO TURN
THAT ANGER AND THAT VIOLENT AS
A PLAYER APARTMENT.
YES, IT'S NOT SERIOUS.
YES, IT SHOWS HOW ALKALINE THE
FOR PROFIT.
A LITTLE WORSE THAN.
THAT IS BISTRO.
>> IF YOU CAN IF YOU DON'T HAVE
TO REMEMBER THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, KEELAN IN
ORDER TO BE NOMINATED TO THE
CHEMISTRY THAT THE HOUSE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A MEMBER.
I'M SURE TRUMP IS LOOKING AT A
SPINNER NOW AND PIVOT YES THAT
ONE VOTE.
I CAN DEFINITELY THAT 205
VOTES.
YOU COVER TRUMP ARE LONGTIME,
HOW THE REACTION TO THAT?
>> I WOULD IMAGINE HIS FIND IN
FURTHER THAN IF IT ALL.
THIS IS AN IDEA OF HIM TALKING
ABOUT ANOTHER.
THAT THE OTHER NOMINATING HIM.
ESPECIALLY, WHAT IT IS ABOUT
THEIR CENTER BACK OF THE
MCCARTHY.
THAT A LITTLE BIT OF A.
AND, FROM THAT WE ARE HAVE
NEVER GOTTEN MCCARTHY.
THERE IS ANOTHER CATALYST ON
THE BOARD.
NOW THEY'RE VOTING AGAINST HIM.
AND OF COURSE, TRUMPET THE
LOOMING OVER ALL OF US ARE NOT
THE WAY HE WANTS.
HE URGED OTHER PUBLIC INTEREST
WITHIN THE MCCARTHY.
THE CHANGE NOTHING.
THE WAY THESE HARD-LINERS GO
BACK INTO GROWTH THAT IGNITED
THE ADVICE.
IT ABOUT THIS ONE IN TODAY AND
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED OBVIOUSLY
AS YOU HEARD THE MANAGER
PUTTING IS NOT EVEN CLOSE OR
STRIKES ME IT IS BACK IN
NEGOTIATION THAT GLOBAL GREEN
HONORS HAD FRANTIC THAT.
MAJORITY OF THOSE ONE THE
DEMOCRAT LEADER THING LEFT 60
PIECE IN THE HOUSE WITH MEXICO
TALKING ABOUT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REASON WHY
THEY DIDN'T GET HER OTHER ONE
OF THE GAS.
.
IT HAS SO MANY MEMBERS WHO ARE
JUST NOT ELECTABLE.
IMAGINE, PART OF BECAUSE THE
ELECTION DENIAL.
>> IT'S NOT JUST MY SHOWING
THIS IS THAT PILLAR HAPPENED IN
THIS COLUMN HALL AND JANUARY
6TH.
HE ANOMALY THAT ISABELLA.
YOU REMEMBER JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS AFTER JANUARY 6TH, IT IS
KEVIN MCCARTHY THAT WENT DOWN
AND SAID TO THE COUNTRY OVERALL
THIS IS OKAY.
DOES NOT HAVE ICY PART OF OUR
DNA.
WITHOUT A 3RD OF JANUARY SIX.
SO, KEVIN MCCARTHY DID THAT IN
A LACK OF RESPECT OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE POLLS AND
INTERCEPTS.
I WOULD KNOW, MANY TIMES THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS EVER SINCE
HE KNEW THAT IT MAR-A-LAGO.
HE DIDN'T THINK DELIVER THE
TITLE OF MINORITY LEADER.
YOU CAN DO MORE OF A FOLLOWER.
I THINK THEY'RE FULLY
UNDERFUNDED BECAUSE WHY THIS IS
NOT LOCKDOWN.
WHY ARE SEEN LOCATION IS
DESCRIBING AS A FRANTIC RAFA
THREAT NOW.
THE FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP.
, THE APPLICATION HERE SEEKING.
IT IS ALREADY SHOWING THREE,
EVEN AT THE END OF THE GAVEL.
--
THE FACT OF A RUN WITH.
>> WHETHER IT INTO AND
MAR-A-LAGO IS EXACTLY FOR
TODAY.
BECAUSE WE WANTED ALL ITEMS
LAUGHING.
BUT WE DIDN'T THINK IT BE WITH
TOP HAMPER THIS.
.
THE UNACCOUNTED LIKE ABOUT
IMPACTS UP AND GETTING THE
MEMBERS.
EMILY EVAN VOTING WITH HIM.
MORE THAN THAT IN THE, YOU
DON'T KNOW BUT IN THE PACKAGE.
THERE'S ALREADY CONCERN THAT
KEVIN MCCARTHY IS GIVING AWAY
THE STORE.
AND OPPOSING THE CHAOS IN
DYSFUNCTION THAT IT IS LIKELY
TO BRING A BIGGER FORWARD.
THEY DON'T KNOW IT SIMILAR.
AND WHEN I COME BACK TO THAT
ONE BOCA DEL MAR COMES.
THEY VOTED UNCLEAR MCCARTHY
ABOUT CURTIS AT THIS POINT.
THEY COULD HAVE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY DIDN'T.
I THINK IS VERY SIGNIFICANT,
THEY'RE NOT SCARED OF FEMINIST
PIECES CLEAR HOW HAS POWER HAS
REALLY DIMINISHED HISTORY.
>> INTRODUCING THE ALL 11, THEY
HAVE THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER IN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THEY'VE ALL DONE BETTER THAN
REPUBLICAN LEADER, EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE A MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE.
>> THE PARTY MEMBERS IN
CANDIDATE IS A LITERALLY
REPUBLICAN HOUSE.
REPUBLICANS ARE FAMILY DIVIDED.
SOME OF THAT ONLY 20.
AND SOME LATE HUNDRED AND 22,
THEY CAN AFFORD.
LOUISIANA.
PEOPLE, HOME THAT NUMBER MOVES
A LITTLE BIT.
FOR THE I'M.
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
DIFFERENT, I GET A.
THEY PASS VERY SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATION.
VERY SIGNIFICANT LEGISLATION.
SOME OF WHICH BECAME LAW.
SOME BADNESS ANNA.
THEY WERE ABLE TO PASS A
SIGNIFICANT, CONTROVERSIAL
LEGISLATION IS A DEMOCRATIC
PARTY FRATERNITY VOTES.
REPUBLICAN DEFENDING 20 PEOPLE
TO MAKE A TYPICAL LEADER.
, SO THIS IS A CHAPTER ONE.
WHOEVER GETS THE GAVEL EITHER
BARIUM, LATER ON AND I
GOVERNING SHE.
, I THINK ARE SAMPLE THAT ARE
BIDEN ACTUALLY GOOD --
PEOPLE TO GO TO THE BOARD.
MILE IF YOU THINK YOU GO TO
WORK TOMORROW.
>> BUT AT THE ACTIVE OPPOSED A
REASONABLE FORCE REVEAL?
I WILL GIVE YOU SOME BORDER
SECURITY THING THAT MANY
DEMOCRAT TO BE MAD ABOUT.
I WILL GET INTO YOUR.
I WILL GIVE IT IF YOU GIVE ME A
GUEST WORKER PROGRAM.
IF YOU ARE FINALLY MAKE THIS
THAT IS IN THE UNITED STATES.
A BILL THAT, WHATEVER
INTERVENTIONS THEM BUT I'VE
DINED BIPARTISAN FOR.
THEY WOULDN'T